hey guys it is the 20th of November
today my name is Jess McDonald and
you're watching games what news if
you're still struggling to get halo the
master chief collection to work you'll
be glad to hear that a patches you out
well nowish this is supposed to fix
those multiplayer connectivity problems
including issues with the netcode lot of
locked players out of accessing the
different multiplayer modes xbox boss
phil spencer has expressed that he's
disappointed with the network problems
for specific things that will be
addressed include matchmaking
performance you I gameplay and title
specific issues you can find all the
nitty-gritty details for the various
fixes in our game spot article the
nominees for the 2014 video game awards
have just been announced and as someone
who openly loves video games and
secretly loves award shows this news is
pretty sweet the show is taking place on
december five but head to gamespot to
see the full breakdown of nominees by
category and have your say on which ones
are worthy of the various awards
categories include game of the year best
indie game best story best remaster and
so on there's also a category for
developer of the year which includes a
controversial nomination for Ubisoft
Montreal at you guys are a little
divided over let me know if you'll be
tuning in it's the Xbox one's first
birthday and Microsoft have released a
stack of statistics pressed to sink our
teeth into more importantly they're
giving away free Kratt the total
gamerscore earned on xbox one is more
than 11 billion while gamers have spent
more than two billion hours playing
games on the console the top 4 most
popular achievements or come from
thoughts and motorsport 5 titanfall
destiny and call of duty ghosts if
you're an xbox one owner who grabbed
your console before november 11 of this
year you can get yourself a free year
one gamer picture xbox one backgrounds a
free rental of halo 4 Forward Unto Dawn
for a limited time and a free rental of
dragon ball z battle of the gods movie
as well as a sample a pack of dragon
ball z tv
sodes if understandably not a lot of
that appeals to you Microsoft are giving
away some actual bundles and games of
what not to select fans at random as for
your question of the day let me know
which game you think deserves to take
out game of the year at the vga awards
for 2014 you can add to gain slot for
more stories on a link dangerous drama
and the pc specs have been revealed from
metal gear solid ground zeroes that is
it for me today do remember that
tomorrow I'll have my top five favorite
stories of the whole gaming week all
ready to go so I hope to see you then